after that massacre at that parkland
Florida high school students turned
activists trained their own political
sights on the NRA launching a boycott
championed by the mainstream media I'm
glad that companies which are what will
stop the NRA from doing what they're
doing and basically killing kids the
companies are gonna be the ones that are
gonna stop this and I'm calling out
every single company right now who is
not in favor of cutting their ties with
the NRA the NRA has shown themselves to
be toxic vile and to not support the
right to light to live which is in the
preamble of the Constitution
I'd say Planned Parenthood maybe hasn't
supported the right to live but look the
NRA has been a business since 1871 and
it does more to promote responsible gun
ownership and gun safety than any
organization in the country the fact is
Nicholas Cruz should never have gotten
his gun because he was a mental case and
he was engaged in criminal threats of
violence at school and on the Internet
the gun control gang has just
misdiagnosed this problem we need to
know the real cause of the Florida
shooting in order to help prevent these
tragedies in the future so I have to ask
you why aren't we looking at the effects
of things like the promise program at
Stoneham Douglass which by the way we
exposed here last night that
incentivized keeping the shooters
disturbing and criminal actions from the
police in an allowed cruise to keep a
clean record and so when he went to buy
guns he wasn't stopped and what about
his tumultuous family life his social
isolation and the possibility that
Cruz's prescription meds might have
triggered some of his mania - we've
heard precious little about that but
instead liberal activists ignore those
and other important factors and they
scapegoated their favorite bogeyman and
political enemy the NRA so what do they
do they kicked off their well
orchestrated boycott and threw so
Media pressure they were able to get
more than a dozen companies Hertz
MetLife BEST WESTERN Windham and
Symantec to end their NRA partnerships
Delta and United Airlines said they
would no longer give discounted fares to
NRA members traveling to their annual
conference but now the Georgia State
Legislature which granted millions of
tax breaks to Delta Airlines decided it
had had just about enough the lawmakers
in Georgia voted to strip Delta which is
headquartered in Atlanta of all of its
heavy jet fuel tax exemptions that cost
a lot Georgia Republican lieutenant
governor Casey Cagle tweeted in part
corporations cannot attack conservatives
and expect us not to fight back well
today at Bastion who's Delta CEO he
issued a memo to employees that the
company was quote in the process of a
review to end group discounts for any
group of politically divisive nature
politically divisive nature our decision
was not made for economic gain and our
values are not for sale but what about
valuing and protecting your customers
why alienate them yeah I was thinking
about today is is getting ready for the
show remember how this line from Obama
went over in Middle America
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh I'm just a bitter clinger I'll never
get over that line but it was so
condescending so insulting and it was
wrong then and what these corporations
are doing to the NRA is wrong now
because of the corporate cowardice of
these companies people who aren't Emma
NRA members are actually considering
joining everything except for this I
think if we stop demonizing all gun
owners we might be able to actually sit
at the table and come up with some
things that would keep guns away from
the people that shouldn't have them I'm
not a member of the NRA but I want to
join now this is an outrage well I'm
telling you this could be the beginning
of a backlash that could be felt by
other businesses in red state America
and right into the midterm election
cycle companies ceding to this political
pressure of the moment think they may
have burnished their brands by pleasing
the New York Times The Washington Post
and pretty much all of Hollywood but
they've also kicked a hornet's nest
offending millions of law-abiding
peaceful Americans who support the
Second Amendment and the NRA
and by the way those people vote too and
that's the angle